Y su primera clase fue "Los revolucionarios intergalácticos y tú"
y América estaba tan emocionada que estaba lista para mostrar su poder:
su habilidad para abrir portales a golpes;
(Risas)
pero inmediatamente le quité ese mecanismo de protección.
Limité sus poderes, la mudé a otro sitio,
y sacudí su mundo porque eso es lo que ocurre en la universidad,
(Risas)
sobre todo si estás sola.
Pero no quise que América estuviera sola por mucho tiempo,
así que gracias a una tarea que le salió mal,
termina en un campo de batalla con los X-Men.
(Risas)
Porque cuando yo estaba en la universidad,
mi mentor fue el reverendo Kelly Brown Douglas,
y allí supe que América Chávez también necesitaría uno.
¿Y quién podría ser un mejor mentor para América Chávez que Tormenta,
la primera superheroína negra
y uno de los miembros más poderosos de los X-Men?
Nadie, solo ella.
(Risas)
Tormenta le enseña a América a calmar su mente
dentro de un portal estelar,
y cuando América lo logra, consigue abrir otras dimensiones,
y en ese silencio
puede escucharlo todo y a todos.
Nadie le había enseñado que el silencio y la reflexión profunda
eran una forma de poder.
Al principio lo rechaza, pero con la motivación de Tormenta
lo consigue,
y América logra silenciar el mundo que la rodea,
y se deja envolver por una profunda vulnerabilidad.
¡Hasta llega abraza a Tormenta!
Genial.
Y eso fue gracias a mis mentores, que me quisieron lo suficiente
para incentivarme a descubrirme a mí misma y a mis ancestros.
Cuando tienes 19 años, ¿cómo sabes siquiera lo que significa eso?
La historia de mi gente no la aprendí en la universidad.
La historia de mi gente la aprendí sentada en el regazo de mi abuela
cuando sacaba el álbum de fotos
y nombraba a todos los que estaban aquí y a los que se quedaron en la isla.
Así que a América Chávez, le tenía que llegar de sorpresa una abuela,
aunque no una abuela cualquiera... sino una abuela luchadora, grande y fuerte,
una que la amara tanto que la llevara al Plano Ancestral
donde América Chávez viera la historia de su gente
proyectada en el cielo.
Y América llega a ver al Planeta Fuertona,
el planeta donde nació su abuela,
y ve cuando el planeta es invadido,
y luego ve a su abuela y a su madre cuando huyen.
También ve la alegría que sintieron
cuando un nuevo hogar las recibió con los brazos abiertos
y les ofreció muchísimo cariño.
América vio que frente al dolor recibieron una gran compasión,
junto a la gran fuerza de su familia.
Así que cada vez que pude,
le dejé pequeñas notas de afecto
para ella y para todos los otros jóvenes 'queer' de color
que tratan de ser fabulosos.
Como cuando te sientes perdido,
buscas dentro del pasado de tu familia y allí conseguirás las respuestas.
También recuerda que el no ser fuerte no te da derecho a aislarte,
esconderte, callarte o acobardarte.
El no ser fuerte también nos empuja
a ser responsables.
Como cuando América llega a la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
y se encuentra frente a frente con Hitler
y le da una golpiza de las buenas...
(Risas)
así como el Capitán América lo hizo en 1941,
y quién diría que América Chávez continuaría combatiendo nazis en el 2018.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Y aun cuando ese acto justificado la afecta un poco,
así que quise que se conectara con su mejor amiga
para hablar de sus sentimientos, y juntas viajan por la carretera
y a todo pulmón cantan "Just a Girl" de No Doubt .
(Risas)
Y cuando Midas, una empresa siniestra
que toma el control de Sotomayor
amenaza cerrar los portales y casi mata a América...
sus ancestros se conectan con ella
porque saben que los necesita para sanar.
Y es ese cariño, esa sanación, lo que le da la energía
para vencer a Midas y recuperarse.
Porque ese mito
de que tienes que enfrentarlo sola y tienes que ser fuerte...
no funciona.
América Chávez es una verdadera supeheroína
pero aun así necesita un equipo que la apoye para encontrarse a sí misma.
Y ella necesitaba de esa ternura,
el tipo de ternura que está enraizada en la compasión,
y está conectada con la justicia y la liberación.
Es en ese espacio donde la vulnerabilidad, la debilidad y la fuerza se encuentran
donde logramos trascender
y convertirnos en algo mucho mejor, algo majestuoso
e incluso, algo súper.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)